A new ore. Lighter than silk. Harder that iron –
as weaponry, it would best the dwarves’ proudest
blades. What is Durin talking about? Find out
about the origin story Tolkien never envisioned.
Season 1 of "The Lord of the Rings: The
Rings of Power" has set out to expand
J.R.R. Tolkien's lore rather than
adapt it beat-for-beat. Of course,
this was always inevitable as the Amazon
series takes place during the Second Age
of Middle-Earth, which isn't covered in
great detail in the author's writings. So,
the show's writers have been tasked with
filling in the blanks in an attempt to create
a fully-realized universe that complements
the "Lord of the Rings" books and movies.
As such, "The Rings of Power" has also been
an unexpected journey at times. The show's
creators have introduced some of their
own ideas into the proceedings as well,
some of which cannot be found in any previous
"Lord of the Rings" story. For example,
Adar will upset Tolkien purists as he's
a brand new character who was created
for the Amazon series. Furthermore, he's
nothing like the Elves in Tolkien's stories,
though his existence indicates that "Rings of
Power" fans can look forward to a few surprises.
The fifth installment of "The Rings of
Power" picks up the pace and continues
the trend of adding fresh elements into the mix,
including one new origin story that
doesn't exist in Tolkien's writings.
Before we get into how "The Rings of
Power" reimagines the origins of mithril,
let's discuss its history in Tolkien's stories.
The "Lord of the Rings" books describe mithril
as a silvery metal that was primarily found
in the Mines of Moria. The material is both
lightweight and strong, which makes it
ideal for creating battle armor. However,
it also boasts a shiny glow that makes it
perfect for creating beautiful jewelry,
meaning that it was often craved by
those who enjoy the finer things in life.
Mithril is viewed as a source of
wealth and power in Middle-earth,
having been worn by some of its most notable
figures. For example, Galadriel's ring, Nenya,
was made of mithril and that's one of
the three Rings of Power that was given
to the Elves. Expect that ring to factor into
"The Rings of Power" sometime in the future.
Of course, any treasure that's so widely craved
brings out the worst in people. Mithril was the
main source of the Dwarves' wealth before their
kingdom was overtaken by the Balrog. Basically,
the Dwarves became greedy and craved
more mithril, causing them to dig deep
into the mines and disrupt the fiery demon
that dwelled in the shadows. Naturally,
the demon wasn't willing to share it with
anyone who entered the mines afterward.
Episode 5 of "The Rings of Power"
sees Gil-galad provide some fresh
insight into the history of mithril.
The Elf connects it to the Silmarils,
which are gems forged by the elf
Fëanor from the Trees of Valinor.
During the episode, Gil-galad tells Elrond
about a legend pertaining to a pure-hearted
Elven warrior who got into a scuffle with the
Balrog over a tree in the Misty Mountains. The
Elf poured all of his good into the tree
to protect it. The Balrog, meanwhile,
tried to destroy the tree and instilled it with
his evil powers. Their combined might caused
lightning to strike, and their powers combined
to create mithril. According to Gil-galad,
the metal is, quote, "as pure and light as
good, as strong and unyielding as evil."
Mithril will now play an important role in
"The Rings of Power" as Gil-galad believes that
it's needed by spring to prevent the Elves from
experiencing a blight in Middle-earth. As such,
Elrond must convince Durin to give the elves some
mithril and save the day. Tolkien didn't associate
mithril with the Silmarils, nor did he have
the Elves require the light to stay fresh. So,
we can chalk this backstory up as another example
of "The Rings of Power" being unpredictable.